Một bạn thằng tư, các quan quản luy không dăng mạng Trung Quốc công bố dức thảo quy định nhằm tăng cường kịp xong hòa đọc của người ảo trên mô trường trình quyền,
theo đó các bạn bộ nộ dung xử dụng người ảo và đập gắn nhản só rằng,
đúng thời bình cấm cùng các cơ giữ buồn có thể gọi hiểu lâm,
phọc tạo quan hệnh thân bật ảo với người dưới mấy đám tuổi nhằm hạn chếng vui cơ ghê nghiệp.
Dương thảo cũng sẽ chặt quy định xử dụng giữ liệu gắn nhăn,
nghiêm cấm tạng người ảo từ thông tin của người khác khi chơi được đồng ý,
cũng như ngăn chạng việc lỗi dụng công nghệ này để quả hệ thông sát thử dụng đình.
Bây giờ, các nổi dùng đe rao ăn nền của ra khích đậm trình sẽ ế hoặc mạng tính bạo lực kêu giấm điều bị cấm.
Cái nên tạng được yêu cầu căng thiệt khi người dùng và giới hiệu được gây hải.
Đúng thế này, cho thấy bắt kênh đang đồng thời túc đẩy phát triển chữ tình nhìn tạo,
và thiết lập các lần dính lò, giấm kưởng sóa trả trẻ liên vực đăng tăng trưởng rất trang này.